en visite au collège jean philippe
rameau de versailles pour la fin des
travaux de reconstruction alain schmitt
président du conseil général des
yvelines a rappelé les actions du
département en faveur des collégiens une
priorité avec la sphère sociale au total
100 millions d'euros soit 10% du budget
du département sont alloués aux 115
collèges publics yvelinois n'est pas une
politique nouvelle qui me mise en oeuvre
mais c'est une politique forte c'est 100
millions d'euros engagés chaque année en
faveur de la politique patrimoniale des
collèges et de tout ce qu'on peut
apporter comme assistance aux collégiens
en termes de transport en termes de
matériel informatique mis à la
disposition car l'une des spécificités
des yvelines c'est l'informatique et le
haut débit le département pionnier en la
matière compte 14 cents tableaux
numériques interactifs au sein des
collèges dix mille ordinateurs pour un
investissement de 1 million 800 mille
euros les zones d'éducation prioritaire
ne sont pas oubliés les collège de
trappes ont notamment été équipés en
zone d'éducation prioritaire bien
entendu c'est important nous apportons
une un supplément si vous voulez dead en
logistique de 25% par rapport à l'apport
classique pour un collège au prorata du
nombre bien sûr de collégiens mais là le
département pour ce qui est des zones
d'éducation prioritaires qui sont au
nombre de 18 il ya 18 collèges qui
s'entend en zep nous apportons 25% de
suppléments en termes d'équipement les
aides font aussi partie de ces collèges
dont les chiffres de la demi pension
sont en augmentation constante
aujourd'hui le département cherche à
harmoniser les tarifs des cinquante
mille repas servis chaque jour pour les
collégiens des collégiens qui voient
leur établissement réhabiliter ou
reconstruits d'année en année parmi les
115 collège 84 sont entièrement neuf
dernier en date le collège philippe de
champaigne du mesnil saint denis au sein
duquel une section pour malvoyants a été
aménagé d'équipements spécifiques